everybody and welcome to the next part
of our Python with flask web development
tutorial video series in the last video
we got our basic website showing up here
and this is what it looks like we just
have this one page though we want to add
some more pages we want to learn some of
the basics about making our website you
know look like a more interesting
website so with that let's go ahead get
started so the first thing I want to do
so come over here to SCP whoops hello
and there's a few things I want to do
immediately in SCP so if you're using
some other program then SCP I highly
suggest you try to do the same thing in
that program but anyway at least in
winscp
you can go options mmm preferences
editors and then you can specify the
specific editor that you want to use for
the specific file type so for my dot PI
files I use idle for my editor and for
every other file I try to use notepad
plus plus so basically for HTML files I
want to use notepad plus plus but for
all Python files I want to use ideally
and just for the record pythons
IDL e is located in this here's the path
to it C colon slash Python 27 Lib / idle
Lib and then you want to use idle dot py
you can use the executable version of
idle it's just going to make a little
window pop up every time it's kind of
annoying but you can do whatever you
want but anyway this is the path to it
just in case
so anyway cool so that's that notepad
plus plus depending on where you've
installed notepad plus plus so these for
me c program files x86 notepad plus plus
notepad plus plus plus
exe if you don't have notepad plus plus
I highly recommend you get it it's a
really great notepad editor kind of
thing it's like a it really is like the
you know plus plus version of notepad so
anyways hit it okay they're all set so
now if you go and open up in it dot PI
for example I double click that
and up pops this for me because I'm
using SCP and I've specified this as my
editor so this is the actual script so I
could go like hey there like this save
that you can see it just uploaded to the
server and then we should we can
probably reflect that yeah and get the
new stuff but if you've just dealt with
an error you maybe just created an error
don't forget to just run service patchy
to start just to be certain on your
updates so we'll come back over whoops I
was going back there we go fresh every
all is well um oh also since we didn't
get a chance
III don't have app dot debug working for
me so I want to show you guys really
quickly um kind of another solution if
app dot debug works for you great but
and also if anybody has a suggestion on
why app dot debug is equals true doesn't
work for me please let me know because
I'd love to have it but anyway so
homepage basically you could you can you
can in case things in try and accept so
you can have try you know something and
then finally return that and then you
can have accept exception comma E so
your typical exception and then return
and then just have it return the string
E and later on you can make this much
more impressive so here we have return
hi there but we can also try X plus five
as well or 56 and in this case hit okay
enter refresh and we see that we got our
air and it says global name X is not
defined so how do we not done try and
accept though and um you know we can tab
this back over save refresh much time
see if shift f5 will do it for us
okay so seriously that's you know you've
got to do a patchy restart
I swear it's like server-side you know
anyway now you get the internal server
error and you have no idea like what
went wrong
that's why app dot debug is so useful
but for whatever reason I can't get it
to work so we'll come back to SCP here
and so we've got a you know returning hi
there but this is actually I mean this
is pretty um pretty useless you know if
you like you have to return see I want
to get rid of this one and anyway so
that's not really that helpful so what
we want to do now is we want to use what
are called we call templates so we use a
template to like load information from
an HTML file and then we can use Python
it pass-through variables into that HTML
file and then we actually also have the
ability to run logic statements through
the HTML file so with that let's go
ahead and show that so come over to SCP
and we're going to go into our templates
directory and right now there's nothing
so let's go ahead and go new file and
I'm going to call this index.html and so
index.html is just going to be um you
know the typical page that we reference
so just so I don't forget everything or
bring a copy of HTML over here and here
we go so for the most part you can get
away with just using HTML tags these
days HTML and then close your HTML tags
if you don't if you're not already
familiar with HTML I wouldn't I
I would suggested can't like look into
maybe some basic HTML tutorials also
JavaScript um just just to get a general
understanding of like how that stuff
kind of works and just so you know like
what's possible and what's not that way
when you come up to a problem you know
what to look for
so anyway in your HTML tags and then
we're going to
our head tags here head and head and
here goes like meta tags and like when
we get a style sheet will throw the
style sheet in there but for now we
don't really have anything that we need
to put in there so I'm gonna put
anything in there and then we have the
body class and this is where like all of
your you know act be de body this is
where it body
goodness this is where I like all your
like actual stuff like your navbar your
logo your actual website content is that
everything goes in the body tag and then
that's about it so now our body tag we
have a couple of things you can have
with HTML 5 you can add in like header
tags so you can have header oh my
goodness header tags you can have footer
tags down bottom too and those will be
like footer but header and footer
corresponds to like groups of things so
like you might think the footer only
goes on the bottom but no there's a
header and footer for like every like if
you throw stuff in what's called a div
tag that's gonna be a header and footer
for that div tag so anyway that's why
it's really useful to look into some
basic HTML tutorials if you're getting
lost but we're hopefully we'll have to
cover too much HTML anyway so that's
okay
so now um we have body and then within
our body so here body you can say body
class equals um we'll just say the main
body but good body okay
now within body you have another body
right and that's what I meant about like
header and footer tags so like you could
have a header and footer to the main
body class but then you've got child
body classes um talking about bodies of
children now anyway body body and then
within these body tags this is where we
can pass some general information so
like let's say let's you know what I
want to make a blog but it's so hard to
like avoid blog like things but say you
want to just make like a basic static
web page right so this static web page
every web page is going to have a title
and we'll say we want the title and
header three tags so kind of bigger font
and then you're going to have you know
some paragraphs
right so some paragraph data sasch P so
like like say here title and then we'll
come into paragraph in that game a
paragraph data paragraph stuff save that
I will come over to putty here run a
quick refresh just to make sure come
over to our website will refresh o
server here what we do what we got going
on C go back to it that PI return hi
there
um oh maybe we just never saved it or
something let's try that again fresh
okay hi there
okay so cool now how do we render the
that template well what you're going to
want to do is you come back over to your
script which is here and instead of
we're just returning text you can return
a template and so to do that we're going
to come up to the top of our script here
it says from flask import flask and in
fact let me configure idle here make it
a little larger so everybody can see it
so from flask import flask and then
comma and we also have an import render
underscore template and it's going to
automatically know to look for templates
in the template directory same thing
with like static stuff so when you have
like a CSS file on some basic JavaScript
stuff it's going to just automatically
kind of not looking at ik although with
CSS file I think yeah you'll still
probably put you all four and then
you'll go into the static directory but
anyway render template always know
looking templates so anyway to find home
page return and so this like let's say
we want to return HTML so we're going to
return render underscore template and
then in parameters you put the template
that you want to return in our case
that's index.html and then there's some
magic that can happen you can add some
more parameters to this and pass through
variables and that's where things get
great but excuse my dog if you hear that
um but we'll get there so hold on let's
restart apache real quick and we come
over here
- and now you see we've rendered our
HTML where we've got title paragraph
stuff okay now this is where the true
magic happens so as I said you can pass
through variables and you can use logic
statements so first let's do this so we
come over to index.html are in our
templates instead of title what we can
say instead is this the following so we
can do what curly braces I suppose the
name of this double curly braces space
title space double curly braces and then
again double curly braces space space
double curly braces and then in here
paragraph and I'm just going to under
case title just because it's going to be
variable so these double curly braces
denote variables in HTML so you'll see
what I mean in a moment so go ahead and
save index.html and now we're going to
come back over to our init dot pi fault
file here and render template index.html
and now we want to pass through a title
variable so we're going to say comma
title equals and then what do we want
the title to be so we're going to say um
epic tutorials and then we're going to
do comma and then we're going to say
paragraph equals and then um wow I am
learning so much great stuff exclamation
mark so we'll save that we'll come over
to our server we'll do a quick restart
come over to our page and we'll refresh
and now we see that actually we've taken
Python we've used Python code and we've
passed variables through to our HTML
page here to basically dynamically load
some text to the screen okay so that's
how we can pass through variables in
from Python to HTML using these these
basically doubles curly braces
now there are a few other things that we
can do we can we can do loops so we can
do like a for loop and we can also do
conditional statements like if else Elif
and all that so that's what we're gonna
be covering in the next video or two so
stay tuned for that if you guys have any
questions or comments on this video feel
free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support the subscriptions and until next
time